when he goes this is Nevada son having
marijuana is just as bad as having
cocaine and in my mind I was like
[Music]
yeah
thank you gentlemen I'm very very funny
man she doesn't actually love him please
give it up for mr. Nick Thune everybody
first time I ever got a laugh from an
audience was in seventh grade English it
was the 10 minutes silent reading point
in the middle of class when the timing
just hit me perfectly to fart and the
class erupted him laughter probably the
best thing they'd ever heard in their
life and then the teacher noticing that
if he were to go against me that he
would lose the class decided to play
along and he said I'll give that a seven
out of ten and in the class again erupt
it into laughter and that's when I
realized that farts are funny they're
always gonna be funny as far as I'm
concerned of farts one of the funniest
things it's best fart joke just a
straight fart and I'm not proud of what
I've done I'm a dad now don't judge me
2008 I was in Las Vegas Nevada for seven
days performing at Planet Hollywood and
my friend Ben Kronberg who's a very
funny stand-up comedian was performing
with me and if you've ever been in Vegas
for longer than three days you know that
it's a suicide mission there should be a
limit like three days we got to kick you
out it's it's not gonna be good for us
it's going to be good for you but I
stuck it out seven days and on the sixth
day of my seven day run we had two shows
and the first show went great in fact a
couple people from Hollywood some
industry was out there gambling they
came to the show afterwards we smoked
some pot and they said hey listen we
know you've got another show but after
your next show there's gonna be a party
at the club at the top of Planet
Hollywood I think it was called Prive at
the time I said go up there and just say
table 60 Isaiah they weren't Isiah that
was just a name of a guy and they said
they'll let you write in table 60 Isaiah
they were like the guy practically owns
the place all right
yeah so we do the next show and after
the show
it's another standing ovation get sick
of him to be honest after a while better
after the show a girl walked up to me
and she had a magazine that was rolled
up as tight as it could be and she
handed me the magazine and she said this
is from Craig and he's a comedian that
had been there the night before and
apparently he wanted to give me
something and as she walked away I
unrolled the magazine and inside this
magazine was cocaine percocets
prescription pain pills a lot of
mushrooms and marijuana
so apparently Craig had leftover drugs
and gave it to somebody and said it
surprised me with it so I looked at all
the drugs and out of all of these drugs
I'd done one of them and I thought you
know what since I've never done
mushrooms a lot of people decide to do
mushrooms for the first time in the
woods with some good friends or maybe at
a great Phish concert I thought why
don't I do it in the most nightmarish
landscape possible Las Vegas so I just
eat some mushrooms and then I'm like
well never had mushrooms before I might
as well throw a couple percocet on top
of it and so there I was feeling like
for the first time like I was living in
a hundred percent and I looked at them
and I said Isaiah table 60 and he said
yeah and we went up to Prive and we
got Isaiah table 60 and we had some
woman escorting us up through whatever
and the walls are vibrating because of
the mushrooms but my feet were vibrating
I think that was the percocet so it just
kind of felt like we were all in sync
and there was Isaiah at table 60 and you
couldn't miss Isaiah he had the body of
George Costanza
with fashion sense a certain type of
fashion senses hair was slicked back use
like a Italian guy and he was wearing a
silk yellow shirt with almost matching
pants he had his name like his initials
they were stitched on to his pocket and
he was he had bottle service at the
table and he was shaking drinks up and
serving everybody he was the king of the
party he practically owns the place is
what I was heard it's what I was heard
and so I sit down and I get introduced
by these industry people like here's
Nick he's the comedian that's here for
the weekend and Isaiah immediately
perked up he was excited to take care of
me we got the comedian here what do you
want what do you want you want to drink
and I was like I don't in my mind I'm
like I don't think I should add that I
don't think I should be adding things at
this point so I was like no I'm good
thanks Isaiah oh the disappointment just
sunk into him the look on his face was
like that's not okay I want to serve you
something and he goes well then what do
you want and I'm looking around this
club and people are dancing and there's
women dancing on tables and it's not
like one girls like should I do it yeah
let's do it
no they're paid to dance on these tables
it's like these models that it's flying
to Vegas on Southwest Airlines you can
see them every week if you want they
come in and do this and they're dancing
on these tables and I just looked at a
girl from across the room and I go
Isaiah her and he was like all right and
he did some hand motion and she was off
that table in seconds and she walked
over and she said what do you want he
goes he wants you and this is a weird
moment where you're like oh yeah who
wouldn't oh my wife wouldn't my wife
definitely wouldn't want me to have her
so I was like oh I was actually joking
Ben and I gave her to Ben and she danced
on Ben first song and then Isaiah gave
her two $100 bills and she went back to
her table and Isaiah was just so
disappointed in me I know that he wanted
to please me in some way so I was
waiting for the opportunity where Isaiah
finally had something for me and then it
happened one of the guys from Los
Angeles that had brought us up to the
table had rolled a joint and that was
going to be their gift for Isaiah for
bringing us up there that night because
weeds actually kind of hard to find in
Las Vegas
I'll tell you more about that later so
the guy took the joint and from across
the table in a very loud room goes
after-hours and he hands the joint to
Isaiah Isaiah looks at the joint and
then looks at me and says huh and I was
like yeah I'll do that and so he lit
this joint up in a very secretive way
handed it to me and now I was just like
and it was like no you got it I'm like
whoa it's I say yeah he practically owns
the place but yeah well hide it so it's
getting passed around the table people
like hiding it going under the leg and
like keeping it down and it came around
two times and hit me as the last person
my third turn with the joint and I took
the last hit and I went to go put it
down by my feet and in that moment I
feel a hand on my shoulder and I turn
around and it's a guy with an earpiece
in and a polo shirt he's a security
guard and then I look around at the
table and people are scattering Isaiah
is jumping over this booth I
don't even know what he's doing he says
people are clearing out and not me and
not Ben and not this agent that was
there from Los Angeles we're all just
stuck at the table and now we're
surrounded by ten security guards all in
polo shirts with the earpieces and they
don't just surround us like there's like
a couple areas where we might be able to
jump through it's like they've
barricaded us with their arms and their
move was this it wasn't grabbing us it
was just like a group walk and they just
slowly group walked us and we're just in
the middle of a circle and I'm like you
know but it feels weird and they they
pull us out and in this kind of big
hallway there's more security guards
these ones have suit jackets on same
earpieces things are starting to change
temperature has changed a lot in the
room I have all of my drugs in this
pocket all of them in my jacket pocket
right here I have my own weed and the
first thing that they notice is that I
look a little more eccentric than the
two other people so they separate all of
us and then everything's focused on me
and they're like what drugs you have
tell us right now and in my mind I was
like let's just give them one at a time
and see if they keep pushing so I pulled
the weed out of my pocket and I'm like
I've got this and so now he's looking at
this this device it's like this wooden
thing with a twist top and there's this
metal bat that Springs out because
there's a spring in there and it likes
jumps out and the guys like what is this
and so I'm starting to explain I'm like
well you take that thing and you put it
in and it gets some weed out and then
you smoke it and he's like turning it
upside down and like there wasn't no
weed and it's just like some specks fall
out at my house and he goes alright
alright and in that moment I realize oh
my god I can't get arrested I'm actually
performing on The Tonight Show four days
from there like I had just shot a pilot
a television show for NBC the week
before I cannot get arrested for all of
these drugs in Las Vegas right now this
is the biggest moment of my life and I
am a fuckup and I hope oh my god
everyone's gonna hate me and my family
and like it's all kind of hitting me and
when you're kind of high on stuff and
you start to take that negative turn it
really goes bad and the one nice thing
was a percocet that was just really
warming my body so I'm standing there
and right in that moment I'm like you
can't arrest me I'm the comedian I'm the
comedian performing here at Planet
Hollywood and that was the moment that
the agent who was in there even though
he's not my agent steps up and he goes
you can't arrest him if you do then I
will never book another comedian in this
casino again and this seemed to affect
something a little bit for a moment and
they're like well the cops are already
on their way so we're just going to take
you guys down to the holding room so now
they take us to an elevator and we're
stuck in this elevator and we're going
down and the vibes are bad and I'm like
it's just wheat it's not a big deal and
he goes this is Nevada son having
marijuana is just as bad as having
cocaine and in my mind I was like what
if you have both we get down to the
basement of the casino they walk us to
this room and they sit us down and now
I'm sitting in this chair and they take
our IDs they tell us the cops are on
their way and one of them puts on some
rubber gloves and he points to Ben and
he says your first standup
and I swear to god Ben jumped up
he'd won the lottery like the
most sarcastic like whoa yeah it's me
and the guys are just like oh this is
and so Ben gets on the wall and he
starts like I mean I think we were all
wondering what the wall felt like you
know initially but Ben was just kind of
do an initial check out like yeah I feel
it's definitely wall like and and the
guy goes hey comedian don't make this
funny this isn't a joke and Ben says how
many movies have I seen this scene in
how can I not make this funny and then
in that moment Ben farted out loud it
rumbled through the room through the
basement of this casino and everybody
erupted in laughter and in that moment
on that share I took my jacket and I
took all the drugs in my pant pocket
while people were laughing hysterically
and put all of the drugs in my jacket
pocket and took my jacket off and rested
it on my chair and just sat there they
finished searching him they said you're
next I stood up they searched me found
nothing searched the agent put my jacket
back on in the middle of all that when
nobody was looking and they gave us back
our IDs and they said alright we're not
gonna have you guys arrested and I knew
it was because they couldn't find the
joint because I later found that it was
still stuck to the bottom of my shoe
which was confusing the out of him
because I was smelling it too and I was
just like you guys missed one area to
search I'll tell you right now they let
us out on a loading dock and there's
some workers smoking and I I walked up
and just feeling just was really feeling
the ground that was moving
and been save my life with a fart now
like I said earlier I always knew that
farts would be funny every time which
proved itself down in that room but I
never knew one would save my life thank
you guys very much
[Music]